He used the the the rler like 10 days ago, you know, like do
not be transparently ignorant and stupid and illiterate. Don't
be all of the worst things and arrogant at the same time. Holy
[__] How about the fact that they choose people with
literal Nazi beliefs all the time, you bald, eggheheaded,
we do the hut stuff right away? You want to just hop into the
hut stuff right away? Yeah. Why not? What? Why not? I tweeted
this this morning. I feel like I incepted him. I feel like I
accepted Hutch completely. Okay, so is at Hutchinson just going
to doom post about Graham Platner's possible downside for weeks
instead of policing the group of lip voters who are refusing
to vote for him? What happened to Blue Noatter who?
What happened to Blue no MATTER WHO, GUYS? WHAT HAPPENED?
And what this is referring to is basically what I thought would
happen. Now, how do I how do I contextualize this properly? When
when people would complain about how not everybody was psyched
about Kla Harris,
I would explain to people
that like, okay, what do you want from from like the lefties?
They they're mad about Gaza. Do you want them to not acknowledge
Gaza? Do you want them to ignore it? Do you want them like what
do you want? Do you want them to just pretend they don't have
any problems?
And a couple of people would lean into that. Yeah, you should
just be enthusiastic about it. You shouldn't be like you should
be happy about it. It shouldn't even cross your mind to consider
talking about uncommitted or something, right? Shouldn't cross
your mind. And
it's like, okay, fine. But now I expect if that's split blue,
no matter who means, I expect for people to kind of like bear
down. And if you don't want to, if you can't like talk about
platinum in a positive way, maybe just ignore it, I guess. Just
endorse and then ignore.
But that's not what we're getting. We're getting Hutch today
spending like hours and hours going over all of the Grand Platner
stuff again.
You know, again, so with this Hutch tweet, I feel like my my
problem is is
when people would say, "Okay, I endorse Kla Harris," but then
talk about the genocide and or when they'd say they're voting
Harris, but they yeah, just talk about the genocide a lot. Many
liberal types would get very upset at them. Very, very upset
at them. No, no, no. You should support her and you should be
happy about it and all this. Not that that mattered for Hutch's
standard because he still hates Kyle Kolinsky even though Kyle
did tons of positive coverage of Kamla, right?
But it's just it's funny. It's like you could just focus on his
downsides. You could just focus on the Nazi tattoo and all of
this repeatedly over and over again. That's one strategy you
could try. It don't really recommend. It seems kind of odd. Seems
kind of awkward, but it's something you could do. I personally
think you should just not talk about it. And I think also what
I wanted Hutch to do was to spend some time on Twitter actually
going after the people who are like, "Oh, no. I can't vote for
Platiner. Oh, no. I don't think I can vote for Platner." And
I'm pretty sure he's like basically arguing like, "Oh, no. I
I get why people can't vote for Platner. I get why people are
concerned about Platner. I get why nobody wants to vote for him."
I feel like he's doing a lot of that. The exact kind of like
hedging and coping that I was hoping he would avoid. It's disingenuous
to not vote for Graham over a tattoo, but to be okay with genocide.
Dude, it's so insane. They are quite If you have this, if you
had the position on Kamla that it was like over the gen genocide
and all of this and now you're like hemming and hawing on plat
platner. You're mad about people not calling it a genocide or
sorry, you're mad about people calling it a genocide. You're
mad about people feeling like they needed an uncommitted movement.
But now with Platiner, you're like, "Oh, no, I understand." You're
essentially saying that a Nazi tattoo is way better or sorry
way worse than the actual genocide happening than aiding in abetting
a genocide. One to one what he with one to one what he did with
Mumani as well. Well yeah the the whole like
and yes this is the example from Mani. It's like blue no matter
who. But like I do get why people are like kind of not wanting
to endorse him. I do get why like we aren't necessarily going
all in on Mum Donnie. Like, oh, I I endorse Mom Donnie, but like
I get why some people wouldn't want to do it. It's like, come
on, man. Come on, man. Just be consistent. Be real.
Or adopt my position, which is like you just have an honest conversation
with people. You can talk about the downsides. Yeah, she is aiding
in abetting a genocide, but she's infinitely better than Trump.
Just allow people to have that conversation.
But that's where the line was drawn for a lot of these people.
It's just like, oh, you know, having trying to protest, trying
to like be upset about Gaza, that wasn't cool, man. Trump was
on the horizon. Like, well, now you could block Trump from having
a majority in the
Shouldn't you also be excited about that,
right?
Okay, that's sort of the background of this. Now, I tweeted this
2:42 a.m. uh Pacific this morning.
Hutch, I believe, spent basically his entire stream watching
Platiner and Platiner related stuff.
If I'm not mistaken, I believe that is what happened. We got
Hutch watching only Platner Platner related stuff. Let me take
a look >> on um on >> the thing about the Platner
situation. The thing that I think about the most is the CNN Kile
interview that came out where they found someone. Why are you
immediately the thing I think about the most shouldn't the thing
you think about the most being like ways you could positively
think about the guy like basically policies you really like things
he's arguing for am I the only person who thinks this that like
hey actually it might be really smart for me to go and look at
policies that this guy's proposing or something I can align with
him on so I could talk about that and then that could be the
thing no who
knew platiner like 15 years ago
claims that platner described his tattoo at the time
as quote my little toten comp
was like 15 years ago. And you might think, oh, okay, well, you
know, they're probably just making that up, right? And that's
what I thought, too. I was a little skeptical. I was like, okay,
well, you know, anybody can make that claim. >> Do you
know who really made that claim, Hutch? Do you know where that
claim comes from? We'll look we'll look into it. But this person
actually showed CNN
their phone because when Platner described his tattoo as my little
totem comp to this person, this person texted somebody else to
talk about it, holy, he just he's got a Nazi tattoo and he said
that it's his little totem comp.
He
So this story is basically somebody reached out to
Oh, what is it? Somebody reached out to Insider
and then Insider wouldn't talk to them. It's an anonymous source,
okay? And basically Insider says, well, here's what happened.
They showed me this this text chain they had with somebody they
said is Graham Platner and they had proved they know they knew
Graeme Platner and that they texted somebody else who wasn't
Graham Platner about Graham Platner's na Nazi tattoo.
Now,
I'm trying to think of Oh, I'm trying to think of like I think
Platiner had an explanation for this, but we'll have to go through
it. I think the explanation was something along the lines of
was it that he wasn't he was like deployed or something at the
time and that person couldn't have had a conversation with him.
I think that was his response, but I'm not totally sure. We'll
we'll
we'll let see. Sorry, we'll see. Hutch goes through the the article
later, so we'll have to see exactly, but I think that was Platiner's
explanation with maybe somebody else about that 15 years ago
and they saw the time stamp. So that person was either playing
the long game
just waiting for this day to come where
and like you know I don't you could your chat can say whatever
they want
but it sure it sure seems like they really don't like Platner
Hutch. It seems like your chat really doesn't like him.
Like what is the what is the effect? I'm just I'm just replaying
the arguments that I said were disingenuous and they would never
apply both ways, right? When they made all these arguments about
Hassan, when they made all these arguments about, you know, Kolinsky
or whoever was was uncommitted, principally uncommitted because
of the genocide,
I said these arguments would never work going the other way.
They would never work. And here we are, right? Here we are. Turns
out the bunch of Nazi people are actually okay with Nazi tattoos
as long as you're running on populism.
It's just disappeared. The blue no matter who stuff has thoroughly
evaporated. All you get is a bunch of snark followed by well
of course I'm going to vote for them.
Well, of course I'm going to vote for him. It's like okay. I
Okay, I guess worst thing about these people is how unfunny they
are. Well, Hutch has like the
I don't even know. I don't even know. I don't know how to describe
the Hutch viewership. I actually don't I don't know how to describe
it. uh Graham Platin would run for national office, you know,
like I I don't know how you fake a text message um timestamp.
That seems pretty complicated. Maybe it's possible. But as soon
as I read that story, I was like, "Okay, well, he's just very
obviously lying." And there's just like that is just dead to
right irrefutable
evidence that he's lying about that. And um like stories like
that are going to just be bombarded. >> Uhhuh. So, this
is the dumerism I was talking about that he just can't stop talking
about how bad it's going to get. Bro, you guys have no idea how
much Republicans are going to donate to talk about the Nazi tattoo.
You guys have no idea. I don't know if you can fake that. It's
irrefutable.
Um, well, I mean, it's an anonymous source who's talking to Insider
who who ran this piece. And I'm sorry, I'm going to say it. I
don't trust Insider to be impartial in this or to really have
done their due diligence. And I would need a second I would need
a second person to go and analyze it and like do their due diligence
here. Sorry. Like I and I'm not man I'm trying to be sensitive
here but I don't trust it because of the biasedness of the source.
I would need like a second source personally whether or not it's
fake. He said contradictory things. If he doesn't know if it
could be faked or if it isn't irrefutable. Oh sure it's I mean
you could definitely fake text messages. That would be very simple
to do.
15 years is a long time to have text saved. It really is. It's
It's a little concerning.
All right. We don't have to watch too much more of this because
eventually I do believe eventually Hutch turns the Medi Hassan
Grand Platner interview on,
right? And that's a whole other thing. We'll get into it.
By the way, nobody likes the Nazi tattoo. Nobody's sitting here
like, "Oh man, the guy with a Nazi tattoo. Give me that guy."
But it speaks to the strength of the candidate and his rhetoric,
right? That he has these issues and he's still wiping the floor
with his opponents.
No, like obviously
upon the people of Maine and [clears throat] campaign ads,
Mills guys, she did not have a lot of money. she did not really
have like
the big criticism of her campaign and there's been a few articles
that have come out since she dropped out is that she never really
like fully launched a campaign and she never really had like
a lot of money on hand to run that campaign. So she ran just
like a small number of ads.
And so the people of Maine have have not yet been inundated by
the political ads talking about Grand Platner's more problematic
uh we'll say
I there was so much earned media on this. Do we really feel like
a lot of people don't know about the tattoo?
Like he had two different campaign managers drop out. It was
a massive news cycle. Did people miss this? I don't feel like
a lot of people missed this,
>> Uh, Hutch, did you know the Nazi from Maine
was trending?
Guys,
we're very online.
Uh,
we're very plugged in. We're very engaged with politics. So,
obviously we know about
Hutch is very plugged, guys. Okay. Very plugged in. >> Platner.
We've known about him for a while, but there are about to be
so like >> Why is he so excited?
What? Hutch, this is bad. Hutch, do you remember that? This is
bad. You're blue no matter who you want this candidate to win.
>> Politics. So, obviously we know about Platner. We've
known about him for a while, but there are about to be so like
the the thing about Platner is like, and here's I'm going to
definitely suggest that people vote for Platner if they live
in Maine, but I'm not going to talk about him very much. >> Okay?
Uh, you should vote for it, but I'm going to just spend all my
time. And by the way, I listen, it's it's your content. You can
do what you want. I'm just saying you were the person who felt
like a lot of people weren't blue no matter who because they
talk about a certain candidate or maybe even certain candidates,
maybe multiple candidates. You felt like that wasn't blue no
matter who. And now those little edge cases are seeming to disappear
because you never like this candidate in the first place.
I'm going to strategically avoid talking about him because the
risk with a
>> Yes, exactly. Tequila Sunset going to do hours of coverage
talking [__] and doing posting after he spent ages
about lefties doing the same thing over Gaza and Kla Harris.
The exact thing he complained about is about to happen on his
stream. And I don't necessarily think you have to lie to your
audience, right? You could dislike somebody. I would probably
try to focus away if I need that person elected. I'd focus away
from negative coverage. I'd maybe explain like how you like a
good way to think about it, a model for thinking about it and
then I'd steer away from coverage. But Hutch is doing a lot of
doom posting >> like Platner is not just limited to Maine.
There's a risk there that he could drive down numbers for other
Democrats if they're seen as tied to him.
And so it'll be interesting to see how much support he gets
from other Democrats.
Um
because you could eas Wait, hold on. I thought I thought everybody
should rally around and support this guy. I thought we should
absolutely get like institutional support here. No. Is this not
a case where we should absolutely get the entire apparatus behind
this person?
Hold on. Do I have a clip for this? I think I have a clip for
this. One second. They say stuff like, "Well, there's only marginal
differences." Marginal? Arginal? What universe do you live on?
This is him talking about 2024. Obviously,
that's what's happening because he spends
eight hours a day, seven days a week telling his audience this
stupid telling his audience that there's marginal differences.
God damn it. It's so stupid. I I just get so frustrated. Don't
ask me these stupid questions. Should I vote for the Democrat,
even if they're like John Federman? Yes. Yes. And you should
do it. Like, it shouldn't even there shouldn't even be an internal
debate. The answer to that question should be so obvious that
the question itself would never even occur to any rational person.
>> You wouldn't you wouldn't question it. It would just
be this clear obvious choice. You live in West Virginia and Joe
Mansion's on your ticket. Enthusiastically vote for Joe Mansion
in that. No, just vote for him. Vote for him and be happy in
that spot. I would.
>> Wow. Okay. Enthusiastically.
All right. All right. We get I'm not getting a lot of enthusiasm
from Hutch here. I'm not feeling the enthusiasm, guys. >> It's
so absurd. It's so bad and it's so absurd that it's like such
a slam dunk layup for Republicans
who want to use him as a cudgel against the rest of the
Like it's so absurd. He like I don't know. I still when I say
the words out
it's still kind of surreal to me. But like, you know, the the
primary voters in Maine, the Dem primary voters in
essentially chose I mean, they didn't vote yet, but like the
polls were pretty clear,
essentially chose a guy with, you know, like a literal Nazi tattoo.
>> I mean, you know, he doesn't have it
You know that he's explained that he got the tattoo removed and
he doesn't have it anymore.
So, you're not even able to maintain like objectivity while you're
talking about it, right?
You're uhhuh. Okay.
I The words escape. >> The audience capture is so funny.
I know I know for a fact that he's it's just audience capture.
Like look at look at the chat, right? Notice Han and this woman
have talked about Trump and Republicans. Basically none.
Populism equals some meaningless term. You already got the Tim
Walls endorsement and support. We'd vote for Platner, but he's
pretty sketch and likes to hide his past statements like Assan
Lamau. He's a Nazi. I'm not going to talk about him. How is this
not the same in fighting y'all the same infighting y'all hate
from the left? Oh,
I see. This guy's calling Hutch out. Oh, okay. I got it. I got
it. This guy's calling him out. Platiner going to win the Republican
vote because of the Nazi shift. That's funny. You think Do you
think Platner is a Nazi or did he have the tattoo that was covered?
I do I do wish Hutch would spend more time talking about that.
Do you think he's a Nazi right now?
Like why are you
The solution to this is just finding your own like position,
right? Is he a Nazi or not? If you think he's not a Nazi,
then shouldn't you be leading with that? Shouldn't you say obviously
like this guy's not a Nazi? Obviously the things he's arguing
for are not Nazi politics, not not Nazi policies, there's nothing.
There's no indication that he's got any of these beliefs. Shouldn't
you be talking about >> My mouth and I'm still just like,
how did we get here? Like what how bad are things where that
happened? Like I don't >> much. and he wants to be used
as a weapon to destroy the party. That's that's a lot, isn't
it? That Platner wants to be used as a weapon to to destroy the
party.
That's a that's a little bit much. >> And so, you know,
you can just imagine the ads that they're going to run, you know,
they're going to run ads about Platiner in other districts
in this country, you know, where there's vulnerable Democrats,
where it's more competitive races. you're going to see uh campaign
ads attacking that
candidate, but using Platner as a proxy to attack the Democratic
candidate in the more moderate districts. And so apparently,
even though nobody knows about Platner, people are going to use
Graham Platner as a candidate to attack Democrats in other districts,
even though he's not even in the Senate yet. Apparently, apparently
that's going to happen.
Really?
I man, I don't know. How does this guy weave between saying he's
like, "Oh, guys, we're too terminally online. This isn't really
the thing." And then he's like, "But Hassan was Hassan us in
the election and Grant Platner, all the all the Republicans in
the count in the country is going to run they're going to run
ads against him. Maybe I'll I'll be more charitable. A bunch
of Republicans in vulnerable damn districts are going to run
ads about Platner.
Why? How wouldn't there be a bunch of other things you'd want
to run on?" I'm just overplaying how much people will care about
this. I barely care and I hate dudes with edgy tattoos. Well,
I think Dems won't care. I think Republicans would be insane
signaling to care. Like, you can't have your most popular influencer
be Nick Fuentes and then pretend you care about this guy's toten
cop tattoo. Okay? You can't be somebody who's probably watching
a decent number of Nick Fuentes clips and then say, "Oh, but
the Ten Cough tattoo, that's too far."
I don't know. If I had to predict like where things are going,
I think you're going to see like a decent amount of Democratic
politicians and candidates all over the country that are basically
going to be forced to condemn
Latner, which is going to feed into
to their grand narrative about, you know, like the progressive
candidates not getting, oh, I thought it was blue no matter who.
They're going to do like that whole
here. I am doing, oh, I thought it was blue no matter who. I
told you explicitly that it wouldn't be this. And Hutch lost
his
He also probably didn't understand what I was saying, but I told
you that it wouldn't be Blue no matter who. You will not get
support. Your candidates will not get support. They will not
get the party support that you think is owed to them. The the
same support that they're demanding of you. Your candidates won't
get it. You got to push through it. You got to be better than
them. Okay? You got to push through it. You got to win in overwhelming
numbers. You got to come out in droves and vote. All right, you
can't get discouraged, but it is already happening. Happening
way sooner than I thought it was going to happen cuz Mills dropped
out. It's just very, very, very funny though. Like this whole
thing. It's so funny that
it's just precisely what I knew would happen. And it's why I
would have liked to talk to Hutch to get this all on the record
from before, right? What What do you think was proper? Cuz this
is all massive
Overt, clear, massive hypocrisy.
And I don't know. I don't know what to do about it, man. >> You
said even Epstein Hutch, time to put that big boy pants on and
vote blue no matter who. Hey, [laughter] >> I will vote
blue no matter who. I'm just saying that like it's really really
scary that this guy's going to like be used against us, man.
I I It is blue no matter who, but like this guy's really scary
and he might destroy Democrats forever. That's all. That's all.
>> Hey, listen. We don't like
he gave he gave me the perfect opportunity to demonstrate my
principles because I meant that when I said blue no matter who.
So if you're in Maine, I think you should obviously vote for
Platner.
And I think he got that Nazi tattoo knowing what it was. And
I think he knew what it was the whole time. And I think he lied
about it. And I think there's no question in my mind that you
should vote for vote for him over Susan Collins. The Senate majority
is way too important.
Way I totally agree with all of this. This is what I thought
lefties should have done. And I think this is what lefties were
doing, right?
I think a lot of lefties were doing this about Gaza. They're
going obviously you got to vote for Kamla. And then they would
talk about Gaza, right? And everybody on Hutch's side of the
aisle lost their [__] about it. Well, it's just reality
that there are certain events or politicians or whatever that
create a drag on the down ballot. That is just a thing that is
real.
And what the Republicans are going to do in the next several
months, they're going to try to milk this for all it's worth.
They've already begun really. Um,
you're already seeing platiner get a lot more
Somebody just said, what did you say a minute ago? What was what
was trending on Twitter today? Nazi from Maine. Was >> Dude,
how much did Platner come up in the Cory Bush conversation with
Hassan? That he was watching Cory Bush and Hassan talk and that
apparently Platner just keeps coming up over and over again >> running
on Twitter. Mike Lee, May 1st, the US Senate candidate running
as a Democrat in Maine has a Nazi tattoo.
Well, technically he did get that covered up
technically. So had
>> it's just so it's so obvious from all of the language
where he leans on this, right? Well, technically
he did get it covered up. I guess
a Nazi tattoo. I did in fact search Nazi from Maine and boy is
there a lot of posts about this.
Um, the Republican party are going to pounce on this
and we would do the same for the record. Like, we would obviously
do the same if the [clears throat] if the Republican primary
voters in a particular state chose
a Republican with a literal Nazi tattoo.
How about the fact that they choose people with literal Nazi
beliefs all the time, you bald, eggheheaded?
How about that? HOW ABOUT YOU TALK about that? Isn't that a good
way to to round out this conversation? These people choose actual
Nazis. These people are putting actual Nazi principles into play
into the political zeitgeist into the Overton window, the heritage
American thing. That's saying that your ethnicity, your your
history in this country matters maybe more than where you've
come from or what you contribute now. How are you how do you
not see them edging towards blood blood and oil arguments and
you don't point that out as a rebuttal to this? But it's because
you don't like this guy. You didn't want him to win in the first
place. You still don't want him to win. Deep down, you are more
spiteful to Hassan or whatever lefty than actually concerned
for America. Deep down, that's the case. So, you can't even muster
like an argument or anything to push back. You have no interest
in pushing back or defending this guy because he's a lefty and
secretly deep down you want him to get crushed in the election.
And that's why he's not going to get any support from you or
people around you. You want him to get crushed. So, it's a signal
to all these people that your politics were right and you were
right. And you put that way above actually winning the Senate,
getting a majority back. You put that way above the good of your
country.
It's just about you, Hutch. That's all it's about.
We would do that to them, too. We would we would say like this
is who they are. This is the whole party. That's the That's the
vulnerability that that Platiner creates. And it and it's not
just limited to Maine. But it is funny because we spent months
and I got a lot of from people from saying stuff like I would
literally vote for, you know, so and so
if they were
so and so. Wait, so and so? Hold on. So and so? Wait, who who
the voted for Jeff Epstein? [laughter]
So I got so much for saying I'd vote for
so and so. solid solid >> for a Democrat and it meant getting
a Senate majority.
I've I've I've put some stuff out there that has been somewhat
controversial
and uh and then and then along comes Platner
and gives me this opportunity to live my principles because I
absolutely think you should vote for Graham
No question.
By the way, this is what I said, right? is he will say you should
vote for this person that Republicans are worse, but that it
will be like a lot of doom posting. This is what I I did not
say I've not ever once intimated that he's not that he's not
blue no matter who in this uh in this precise way that he will
still endorse, right? But when it was blue no matter who for
Kla Harris or anybody else, he spent all of his time attacking
the people who were denigrating the candidate and now it's blue
no matter who and he's going to spend his time attacking the
candidate or talking about the downsides of the candidate AND
THEN GOING BUT you should vote for Platner. But you should probably
vote for Platner anyway. >> Jug Runner with $5 is the best
strategy to get Platiner elected to mention his tattoo and everything
you dislike about him whenever he comes up.
[screaming]
>> Is that Do you think that's the best strategy, Hutch,
to just constantly doom post about him every single time? Every
single time he's brought up. You're going to That's a great question.
That's a great dodo. Thank you.
>> I mean, listen, probably not. But like, I just
Okay, probably not.
Does that mean you're going to not do this anymore? Does this
mean you're going to stop at the doom posting or what do you
guys think? Is he going to stop? Well, probably not.
Probably not the best choice, guys. I don't think I'm going to
do my best job to get Grand Platner elected if I keep doom posting.
>> Uh,
here's what I think. I think I think if people deny the obvious,
that's not going to help him.
I
dude like sort of when people were like, "Oh, if we if we don't
talk about the gods of genocide, that's not going to help her.
We're all upset about it." Like even even if we lie and pretend
that it's not happening. It's not going to help. We all know
it's happening. What does What does lying help? He didn't like
these arguments before, man. He liked none of these
>> here. I'm going to let it I'm going to let it play as
one section here. Okay.
>> hold on. Hold on. assume she did. I you know Jug Runner
with $5 is the best strategy to get Platiner elected to mention
his tattoo and everything you dislike about him whenever he comes
up.
I mean listen probably not but like I just uh here's what I think.
I think I think if people deny the obvious that's not going to
help him.
I just I don't know what to do about platiner to be
>> We don't have to deny the obvious. I
How does Hutch still not understand
When you don't have a good defense, the best defense is a good
offense.
Well, you know, technically your secretary of state has some
tattoos that are kind of white nationalistic iconography and
that didn't really bother him. You you openly associate with
Nazis or white nationalists in your party. You openly have some
of your biggest influencers are essentially open white nationalists,
too. So, realistically, what am I what am I considering when
Republicans pretend to be mad about this tattoo? Oh, nothing.
Nothing at all. You actually shouldn't take it seriously ever.
>> Honest with you, I don't know how to handle that situation.
I find it just
>> All of this guy's political instincts are totally broken.
He's got nothing. There is just nothing going on upstairs. Absolutely
nothing going on upstairs. Hey, didn't you guys basically have
like a doesn't like a an open white nationalist make threats
to your party's political leaders, including the vice president?
Hey, if you talk [__] about me, JD Vance, I'll go
I'll go against you. I'll campaign against you. And and then
the JD Vance is like, "Oh,
you're real. You're a real Mr. Nick Fente. You're a real actually.
I think you're kind of a" And then he never says anything publicly.
Nick Fentes calls his wife a slur and JD Vance is like, "You're
just a real man. I don't know what else to say." Golly G. Golly
G, you're a real buddy.
That's that's the Republican side. Okay. They literally have
an open avowed white nationalist who can terrorize the vice president
of the United States. Spare me with your concern about a possible
Nazi tattoo from somebody who has never once
ever stated a single thing that lines up with Nazi ideology.
>> I find the whole situation just incredible. It's like
something out of a movie. It's incredible to me. Did Cory Bush
endorse Kamla in 2024? Yes. And notably, she was the first member
of the squad to do so.
Bush endorse Kla Harris on Sunday, July 21st, 2024.
This is the uh Oh Jesus. This is like the Hutch community
like exit question. The escape hatch question.
Did she endorse Kamla in 2024? If she didn't, I don't have to
listen to anything she says. This person, bro, do you I swear
and I I don't want to give myself too much credit, but do you
think I like somehow mind controlled this guy into actually doing
this? Because again, I posted this before his stream like this
morning, right?
Do you think he like saw this post and was like I I am going
to talk about platiner a lot today?
Like I don't know. Is it Did I SCop him into doing it or what
happened here?
I don't even know how to explain it, >> In Maine. And so
I think like moving forward I'm just gonna I'm gonna focus
and I've I've done this a little bit so far, but I'm going to
focus on the broader goals of winning a Senate majority
because I if I like I can't really defend him. I can't really
defend him in a way that lines up with my principles. Like I'm
not going to lie. Like I >> Do you think he's a Nazi?
Do you think he has Nazi beliefs?
You think he's a Nazi ideologically? You could say I mean I unless
he doesn't believe this. Unless he believes that this guy's an
ideological Nazi who somehow fooled everybody into running as
a progressive. Okay. Couldn't you just say something like the
Nazi tattoo? It looks like really bad judgment to me. It looks
like he had a pretty dark past. I think he's actually lied about
it because he knows it is a political liability.
But I do think the change is sincere. I do think he's sincere
about making Mayor's lives better. And I think I would and I
know I would support him no matter what. Not just because I think
he's made some sincere changes, but because I know that it's
dire for Democrats. It's of dire importance we get the majority
back in the Senate.
Holy holy. Is that not super easy?
How is that difficult?
If Hutch needs me to write the talking points for him that align
with his ideals cuz he can't think of them himself cuz he's too
busy fantasizing about how much he could crucify lefties. If
Platner loses, then I will do that. I'll write all those talking
points out for him. I'll add him on Twitter and I'll send them.
Okay? And then he can figure it out. He he's got them, right?
Maybe I'll do that at some point. I'll go ahead. I'll say, "Hutch,
here's how you defend him in a way that aligns with your values."
Cuz Hutch apparently can't conceive of it. Dem Dubois with $5.
The tattoo is weird. You just can't brush that aside. Unambigu
unambiguously Nazi. I mean, we're in unprecedented territory.
Like as a Democratic Party
as a lifelong Democratic Party supporter,
this is very new waters I'm charting here. Okay. I've never had
to be I I've never been confronted with a national candidate
who just like had an unambiguous Nazi tattoo.
Again, this is all about Hold on. He He It's like he says the
words, but he doesn't understand the theory behind it, right?
Cuz if you understand the theory behind blue no matter who, you
can easily handle this in the exact way I can. Watch. The Republican
party is overtly captured by people with very sympathetic views
to the Nazi regime and Adolf Hitler. This is proven out. Young
Republican group chat leaks. Okay, I don't give a about your
virtue signaling Republicans. You guys haven't even got rid of
these dudes. Some of these dudes still have jobs.
You don't care about it. Why pretend you care about it? one of
the most popular influencers, young influencers of the on the
Republican side, is overtly sympathetic to the Nazi regime and
Adolf Hitler directly says as much in multiple interviews. That
guy has a ton of influence such that your vice president [__]
out to him. Okay,
what else? Um, the heritage American stuff is obviously some
white nationalist rhetoric seeping into your into your actual
party's mainstream rhetoric. I don't give a about any of your
virtue signaling. You don't care about this. I can at least say
this guy's changed. I can say I've seen it to his private life,
his private thoughts through his Reddit account, and that he
doesn't have any overt Nazi ideology. It's just not there. When
I see it to your your politicians, your aids, your staffers's
private thoughts, there's overt Nazi ideology.
So, it's a massive difference. You just attack the obviously
worse party because you believe they're obviously worse. If you
can't define why they're obviously worse, if you can't explain
why they're obviously worse, then why the are you even arguing
for blue no matter who? if you don't believe it, Hutch. So again,
I'm just hoping somebody sends any of these clips to him, any
of these clips so that he can figure out a way to talk about
this that doesn't actually ruin or or sorry, not even ruin cuz
he can't ruin. I will give him that. He can't ruin it. But if
you want to actually maintain your beliefs or maintain your principles
and really try to commit to blue no matter who, just explain
it. Explain it to people. Explain how they should respond to
it. It is you compare them to the other side. You understand
that in every other case. You sure as understood it with Gaza,
right? Oh, you don't want to vote for Kla Harris because of the
Gaza thing. Oh, don't you understand that Trump would be so much
worse? Look, it's so easy and you do get it because you've done
it before >> and then like obviously lied about that. Like
I you know, you have to kind of laugh. All I can do is laugh
to make, you know, I'm just going to laugh through the pain.
How do you know that thread Reddit thread wasn't where he learned?
I mean, come on. There's no way you guys are there's no way you
guys think that he didn't. The Reddit thread is not very conceivable
he learned nothing or didn't even see that what the Reddit thread
was about. Very >> No, right. Like there's no way you actually
think that, right?
>> Um but I I would assume he knew before that. Like I
sorry I'm in my head in my mental model he knew before that but
it's very possible he didn't even see that that thread was about
a toteen cough. Very possible. He clicked in the comments saw
something. I think what is he talking about in that? Like he's
defending people who get like the the super sniper tattoo, right?
How many more like things have to be presented? Let me ask you,
how do you explain? This [clears throat] is important. Okay,
this is really important. This this this to me was like more
damning than all the Reddit posts and his just really quite frankly
um
implausible explanation. Um, how do you explain the fact that
CNN
talked to someone
who Grant Platiner told this person like over 10 years ago that's
that called his tattoo my little toten comp.
And then how do you how do you explain the fact that CNN looked
at this person's
text
and there's a text message from over years ago
with a time stamp and everything of this person talking to another
person and saying what the he just called it his little totem
comp. Like how do you explain that? It's impossible to explain.
The only way you >> uh I can easily explain it by calling
it out as an obvious forgery, an obvious fake and you are a rude
for believing it in the first place.
>> God man. EXPLAIN THAT AS if he knew about it and he's
just lying about it right now. There's a time stamp on the phone.
You can't fake time stamps like that. It's just that that's not
how that that works. >> You absolutely what
I know Hutch doesn't know that because he's already talked about
it like about 30 minutes before this in the VOD. He said he didn't
know if it was possible and now he's just saying you can't fake
it. YOU CAN'T YOU COULDN'T POSSIBLY DO THAT on 15year-old texts.
What?
As soon as I saw that, I was like, "Okay, well, this is just
dead to rides."
Um, Platin knew and lied, but I don't think he's a real Nazi,
so I support him. My head cannon about
Platner is that there are a lot of people with politics that
we might consider like incoherent.
It does appear that he whatever you whether you want to call
it radicalized or persuaded but it does appear that he at some
point discovered leftist politics and genuinely believes in leftist
politics
and so like my head cannon is that you know he was a Why don't
you say that when people bring up the tattoo? Why don't you say
that when when people bring up the tattoo? Why didn't you say,
"Oh, I believe he's I as much as I think he may have known what
that tattoo was or may have had some bad beliefs in the past,
I think he's made a genuine shift towards like leftist, populist,
empathetic politics."
>> How hard is that, man? >> A bit different
in his youth and then genuinely changed. Like, I don't think
he's a literal Nazi anymore. >> What evidence do you have
that he was a literal Nazi other than the tattoo and his explanation
of because he's defending people with that super sniper tattoo,
right? the SS tattoo and he explicitly says there a lot of people
who have some offensive tattoos in the military who don't know
what you're talking about and got this in solidarity with their
boys. Like that's the way and maybe that is a maybe that's what
he means when um he's talking about the Reddit posts, right?
Like it seems pretty clear that he has never expressed any Nazi
ideology anywhere anybody could point to.
In fact, I think one of the posts in that Reddit thread or one
of the posts he made on Reddit was something like, "Oh, so you
think anybody who's got this tattoo is like a racist? I guess
I'll let like all my black brothers know, like all my black military
brothers or all my my friends who are in platoon with a bunch
of black guys or the black guys who have this tattoo, I guess
I'll let them all know that they're actually Nazis. But, you
know, he is just obviously lying about it. Just very obviously
lying about it. And I just to me I I just have a lot of there's
a lot of question marks about his jud >> Oh, this jug this
Jugrunner guy keeps throwing out good super chats. The way a
lot of libs talk about him will only hurt him on top of the Republican
attacks. Not a good strategy in my opinion. We're falling into
a trap. That's true. That is true.
Now, if you were like me, I would say, listen, I think honesty
is the best policy. You can't like just lie about stuff. But
there are ways you could message to minimize the downsides and
talk about like redemption, how he's a better person, right?
A lot of people in the military get into that stuff without really
buying into the ideology overall and realize how toxic or harmful
it is after they leave,
right? Like they might get a tattoo or they might get something
wo like sewn onto their uniform or right, they might do these
things without really understanding it or thinking about it and
then realize, oh, that would be harmful when they leave.
a lot of question marks about his judgment. Lefty media was blaming
the discovery of his old Reddit posts on like
DSC,
you know, oppo research
or like the establishment like went after him because why are
you talking about lefties right now?
Why in the world? Why did you just start talking about
OH, I THE BOOGEYMAN IS not real. Okay. Despite what many people
say, the boogeyman cannot get you. He's not under your bed. Can't
get you. >> Watch him with John Stewart sometimes. The
first 15 minutes he explains a lot. Well, you know what we still
haven't watched is the Medi Hassan. >> Oh, something that
pates him in a positive light. No, no, no, no. I heard Medi Hassan
pressed him. So, let's check that out. >> Yeah, cuz like
Medi Medi Hassan is um usually like pretty pretty good at pressing
people. So, we'll see. Did he was he tough on Liner or did he
use kid
>> So, on that note, a perfect segue into what I want to
talk about next. I know you've spoken about this before, but
it's the first time you and I speaking about any of this. the
biggest single controversy of your campaign, which is not going
to go away if Susan Collins has a way. Is a tattoo you got in
2007 that you since had of a skull and crossbones that resembles
a very infamous Nazi symbol. You said you had no idea about the
connection, saying quote, "I absolutely would not." >> Uh,
I mean, even that felt a little whitewashy to me, even just the
way he framed that question. And Medi is usually like good at
pressing people.
Um, you have tattoos. You should know how many of us tattoo heads
keep tattoos we don't like for many years cuz it is a hassle
to remove. I I mean, yes, but that usually applies to like, you
know, dragon tattoos,
not like explicit Nazi iconography. There's a difference there,
I think. >> Not have gone through life having this on my
chest if I knew that. When exactly did you find out that the
tattoo on your chest could be a Nazi tattoo or seen as >> Oh,
about 3 or 4 days before I had it covered up. >> No, no,
I'm sorry. No, no, that is impossible to believe, my good sir.
>> I So, I I got that tattoo with some other Marines whether
we're on short.
>> Okay. Impossible to believe. I I tend to agree. I tend
to agree. All right.
But at least for the text messages, I think he's got like a response
to this that I want to see how Hutch handles it cuz I do believe
he responds to that
Insider article and I think he has an explanation 2007 and then
I had it for 17 years. I went through two security clearances.
I reinlisted the United States Army. Got screen. >> It's
the first time I'm hearing this. Wait, are you serious? Uh, just
type yes or no in chat. Did you know about Grand Platner's Nazi
tattoo before talking about it today on stream? I assume most
of you knew, but are there going to be some people that are that
are know? >> I can't believe there are no in literally
everybody knew. Everybody in chat knew. Okay. >> For gang
and hate tattoos. >> Yeah, you guys are weirdos that spend
>> too much time online. >> People are joking. It
is politics. Politics. Politics. Weirdos. >> And then I
went to work for the state department on the ambassador security
team in Kbble where I got a top secret clearance and also got
screened. Never came up. I took my shirt off in front of my extended
family. the entire time. I would not have done that if I thought
I had some obviously recognizable white supremacist or Nazi symbol.
>> So, uh, the Badger with 1041. Thank you so much. >> So,
so Graham, why then, and that all sounds perfectly reasonable,
especially the the security checks. So, why then did a former
top official on your campaign, Genevie McDonald, your former
political director, tell the Guardian last year, while he may
not have known what his tattoo meant when he selected the image,
it's not plausible he remained ignorant of its meaning all these
years.
>> I I don't know why she said that. Uh, she was only on
the campaign for a little over a month. They offered her $15,000
to sign an NDA and she said she could have used that money and
she said no and came I I'll be real.
People would
people would pay more, right, for that to come out in the other
direction. I'm sorry. 15 grand is that did his did his campaign
really have that little money? 15 grand was all they could Yeah.
I'm sorry. There'd be way more on the other side of that. But
regardless,
what did she why did they offer 15 grand for an NDA? What did
she say? Cuz that's not enough for the NDA that oh, I don't believe
that he wouldn't have because that's just logic, right? I don't
think he could have gone 19 years without realizing or hearing
what it was >> and and went public with her concerns about
him as a >> You know what I would You know what I would
have thought for sure was somebody told him what it was and he
just coped and was like, "No, it's not." You know what I mean?
Like because that's more likely what happened here. Somebody
probably told him at some point about anything about anything
close to this and that it was like a Nazi symbol or it looks
like a Nazi symbol and I guarantee he was like so offended by
it that if he was told that he like kind of in his head was like
no it's not. No it's not. You're crazy. I'm not a Nazi. And then
just had it like locked in his head that it wasn't until it became
incontrovertible that it was >> and would not have known
my anything about things I would have known. >> uh she
she quit uh in rather spectacular fashion and then spent some
time >> yeah saying deprecating things about the campaign
and about myself. >> Okay. And why did why did CNN report
that they spoke to an acquaintance of yours from more than a
decade ago? See this this one guys this one is so damning. I
have no idea how he's going to explain this one. >> Who
said you >> Yeah. saying deprecating things about the campaign
about myself. >> Okay. Why did why did CNN report that
they spoke to an acquaintance of yours from more than a decade
ago who said you talked to him about your tattoo resembling a
Nazi symbol? Well, I believe they actually reported on a insider
uh investigation which had spoken to one anonymous person. Uh
>> I don't think that's true. Uh
I Oh,
are we are we coping? I'm pretty sure I looked it up and that
was the case, but I understand it's a K file article that is
reusing reporting from another article, but I'm pretty sure the
source is the is literally the Insider article on him. >> That
was my recollection was that they directly spoke with the friend
and and looked at the friend's uh text messages with timestamps.
Okay, like dead to rights, you guys. ation uncovering deleted
social posts that undercut claims by a Democratic Senate candidate
in Maine. Graham Platner, a Marine veteran, announcing this week
he covered up a tattoo on his chest with Nazi imagery and claimed
that he didn't know the meaning when he originally got that tattoo.
Our K file found past and since deleted social media comments
of him defending the use of Nazi symbolism. Andrew Kazinski is
out front. Andrew, what have you learned? Well, Dana, we found
an old Reddit post from Graham Clner where he writes about the
use of skull imagery in the military. It appeared on Redd about
the toading comp, which is the Nazi.
>> So, this isn't him, right?
This isn't this isn't him who's posting this. So, >> version
of the skull and crossbones, and it looks a lot like the tattoo
that Platiner had on his chest. Now, someone on the thread brings
up the fact that some Navy Seals use a so-called Punisher skull
as their emblem. >> So, Hutch is making faces. Am I crazy
or are they implying that that's him making that post?
I'm pretty confident that's not him. Am I crazy?
I'm pretty sure that's literally not him who talked about the
Totenkov.
Like I think Hutch believes that this was I think Hutch believed
that the previous posts were him. He's making faces like he believes
the previous posts were Graham Platner making those posts, right?
That definitely undercuts or certainly undercuts a little bit.
Uh claim >> a lot. It undercuts a lot. Okay. Mega airhead
with 16 months of being a member. Thank you so much. Nazi tattoo
guy hasn't earned my vote. >> Claims that he only recently
found out about it resembling Nazi imagery. What else did you
find on Reddit? So we found that in 20.
>> So again,
15 years ago that this came out and they're like, "Oh, he showed
us a text chain." I sincerely sincerely
doubt this. I I'm sorry. I really sincerely do. If this were
true, I think these people would want to be on the >> I
mean, to be honest with you, like the initial story to me is
plausible. For the record,
it is plausible that he and his fellow Marines went to a tattoo
shop in Croatia and just didn't understand that the image that
they were getting tattooed on their bodies was explicit Nazi
Nazi iconography. But what is impossible to believe that he is
that he just didn't he didn't become aware of that after the
fact. He didn't become aware of that until, you know, a few days
before he got the tattoo removed. I think at some point he figured
out what it was. Um K follows Andrew Kazinski. Well, hold on.
I'm going to The fact that CNN wants to stamp their reputation
on this means
It absolutely does. Like I'm not going to totally discount this
now that I so when I originally heard about this and I looked
into it like a little bit, it was that this was basically them
But I guess I man I I feel bad cuz I guess I didn't look into
it enough. But
if it's just Kfile who's saying that we talked to these people,
I think they're putting the reputation behind it. Now, I think
Platiner has some explanation here,
but it's not good enough for now that I'm seeing this like laid
out with that it's Andrew Kazinski putting his name on it, he's
got CNN's reputation and they're they're backing for it.
I would want to know what they did with the phone or how they
looked at the screenshots or whatever it is, right? Personally,
cuz this does still feel like a story that could easily be planted.
if they saw a screenshot, if they didn't open up the the app,
and if they are not looking at the phone at all, I'm very concerned
still. But it's it's a different ballgame if it's not them re-reporting
somebody else's reporting. That's a far more biased, less trustable
source. >> Yeah, it's completely plausible that he him
and his friends got drunk and went to a Croatian. It's like an
episode of like Seinfeld, you know what I mean? Or like it's
it's like an episode of uh It's Always Sunny in Philadelphia.
Like the whole thing is just so absurd and kind of funny. You
keep calling him a liar. Well, listen, Captain Flavor Town, I
just want What is What is
How do you explain >> Flavor Town >> CNN looking
at a text message exchange with timestamps from over a decade
ago of two people having a discussion
about Platiner's tattoo and what he said about the tattoo at
the time? Like, how how do you explain that? Fake news. Fake
news. Like, how do you explain that? To me, that's just like,
well, to me, that is impossible to explain. I don't know how
to explain that other than, okay, he's just lying about it now.
Um, I think the weird thing is I don't like how they originally
presented this. >> He's lying about when he found out.
That is specifically
what I think we know for sure. What we know for sure is that
he's lying about when he found out it was a Nazi tattoo.
Can you imagine, you guys? Can you imagine? This is the This
is No, no. Don't do the anonymous source thing, bro. Don't do
that. They showed CNN the text exchange 10 years ago. >> I
again I I question the text exchange. I would just want to know.
I would want to hear or see what they did with that phone if
it was like what they were shown precisely
>> years ago of them discussing what Platiner had said
about that tattoo. Who cares if it's anonymous source? CNN saw
the text messages. How do you explain
>> There's no explaining that in a way that makes any sense.
You just can't explain >> What they're talking about is
pretty epic. Although I do understand that our world is foreign
and in insulated >> Did you see them? So, okay. Are you
going with CNN is just lying?
Is that what you're going with? Are you going with KFIL? Kfile,
whatever your feelings on CNN, Kfile is an established
like what's the analog? What's that one uh Spotlight? You guys
saw that movie Spotlight? You guys see the movie Spotlight?
It's like a division within
the Boston Herald, I think, or I don't know where the Whatever
this is the I mean, I don't know about the Boston Herald. Oh,
is this to do with um the Catholic priest? Okay. I'm just saying
I I agree that if I don't care really that it's anonymously sourced.
I want to know what they did for due diligence looking at that
phone. Kil is like a specific division like subgroup within CNN
and they're known for exhaustive
reporting on stuff like this. And so I sure it's possible that
Kfile is like lying about what they saw in those text messages,
but >> most people have no idea how it works. Later in
the same post, Blatner says the SS lightning bolt tattoos were
part of a culture in Marine sniper units. This looks uh um a
little different from a Reddit post archive, but when you read
through the post, you can actually see um Flater talking about
this. You know, he says, "This is a culture that I am close to,
that I know intimately." He says, "I'm not being up to I'm explaining
something that is far more nuanced than you're willing to understand."
He was pushing back basically on people who were saying uh that
this looks like, you know, a Nazi.
>> Realize Hutch is misunderstanding the reporting. The
texts were from a few months before the story went public, not
a decade ago. We can grab the archive version of this and let's
look at the the providence of the text chain. CNN also reviewed
a text chain between the acquaintance and another person discussing
Platner's Nazi like tattoo several months ago before the story
became public.
Okay.
Oh, that's way different. Yeah, he is misunderstanding then.
This is not from a week ago. Pler said in an interview this week
he got the skull and crossbones tattoo in 2007 when he was in
his 20s in the Marine Corps in during a night of drinking while
on leave in Croatia, adding he was aware until recently that
the image had been associated with Nazis, not a secret Nazi.
Following the wave of news coverage this week, Platner had has
had the tattoo covered up. His campaign has since fielded questions
about whether Platner was aware of the tattoo's resemblance earlier
than he has said. Insider first reported about THE FORMER ACQUAINTANCE.
OH, I SEE.
OH, see this is ah boy that's where that's where I immediately
am like these guy this guy materialized out of nowhere. Oh my
god.
I'm sorry. I'm doing a little bit of it. A little bit. I I've
earned.1% of this. Okay. Bit of McDonald Platner's former political
director told the Banger Daily News that she has been aware of
the tattoo since at least August and that Platner himself acknowledged
it could it could be problematic. Platner's campaign has dismissed
both the Jewish insider report and its former political director's
claims is false. Screening and Platner, political novice, increased
earlier this month after Kfile revealed that he'd used the deleted
Reddit account to call himself a communist. Oh, he did call himself
a communist on there. Okay. And uh dismiss all police as bastards
and to say rural white Americans are actually are racist and
stupid among other inflammatory remarks. Platner disavowed the
post and said that they came at a time in his life when he was
angry.
The former acquaintance told Jewish insider recently speak on
the condition of anonymity to address a sensitive issue. He said
it in a cutesy little way. The exchange occurred in 2012 at TuneIn,
a popular dive on Capitol Hill where Platiner later worked as
a bartender. Okay, so this was said in person by Platner.
So this guy told the told the dude in person in 2012. Okay, so
that's where this comes from is 2012. now because I believe that
what Platner says as a response to this is yeah in 2012 I was
literally deployed
I'm pretty sure that's his response >> we reached out to
Platner's campaign uh Dana you know he talked to us a lot last
week before that first story that we did this time we didn't
uh get a comment from them >> it was years they said they
knew me from when I worked at a bar from years I didn't even
work at that bar okay >> and so you're you're denying that
allegation just to be clear >> oh yeah absolutely
>> okay so again if the guy was claiming 2012 and Platiner
didn't work there in
Does that not ring some alarm bells for people? Right now, let's
see. Now, let's see what turns on in Hutch's brain here cuz I
I just found out that actually I was right all along. I was right
all along and I knew I had that. Listen, I literally just looked
up this article in my own I had this article in my Discord already,
right? So, I'd read this article before. I'm not crazy. I just
couldn't source it. I'm not crazy. I read the article. I wasn't
just blaming. I WASN'T. I WASN'T. I READ THE ARTICLE. I READ
THE ARTICLE. OKAY. Oh my god. I I was like, "Ooh, that looks
bad that I blamed insider." And then I didn't even know. I didn't
even source it. I did. I went and looked it up, but I just forgot.
How do you explain the time stamp on the text message? How do
you explain that 10 years ago?
>> Yeah. If If the guy If the guy was had a text message
from 2012 when he was talking about it, which is what I believe
it says in the insider article,
right? is it was supposed to be contemporaneous.
So, this guy had a mis he misremembered something about Platiner
maybe and then he told a friend about it years and years later.
I'm sorry. In my mind, the way this worked is they disco somebody
discovers this wedding footage as they're doing background checks
into Platiner, like an oppositional figure. Okay.
They leak that he has this tattoo to this place. This place tries
to find somebody who says they've talked to him, right? and basically
goes, "Oh, you know, we're gonna we're going to plant this story."
And they say, "Okay, well, he worked here. This is where I would
have met him." And and basically,
once you get to the details of this happening in 2012, and then
the text messages being leaked around the time people would have
been doing opposition research, that's where the text messages
are from, right?
So, this is from also reviewed a text chain between the acquaintance
and another person discussing Platiners's Nazi like tattoos several
months ago. So in 2026 2025 rather he's discussing this with
somebody. So apparently he had never discussed it with anybody
and then around the time people would have been doing OPA research
on Graham Platner.
That's when he's talking about it to
Dude, this is Yeah, you can't get filtered by this. I'm sorry.
Oh my god. Would people want to argue about this? I think this
is fake.
This is with me right now cuz Medazison is like literally the
hard ball interviewer. He's like the guy. I can understand what
you're saying and I'm hearing your denials and and the point
about your extended family. It makes sense and you're a progressive
so people are giving you a lot of leeway because they like your
policy platform. [snorts] But surely [laughter] you would admit
if you were a Republican who would be found with that tattoo
on your chest. People progressives Democrats would be losing
their minds, wouldn't they not? Why do you care about a tattoo
he got over a decade ago? What? See, this is what is freaking
me the out about this moment.
That question freaks me the out.
>> Yeah, that's definitely just somebody with you. >> Like,
how bad are things in America right now? How bad are things on
the left right now that I'm being asked that question?
Does Hutch care that Medi Hassan's basically saying, "You understand
that like nobody believes you, right?
Come on, man. Come on, man. You understand like nobody believes
you, right? You understand if this is a Republican, like we would
never believe them. Why am I How the can I possibly believe you
in this?
about like a literal Nazi tattoo.
>> Dare I say Medi Hassan might be slotkkins this guy.
Okay, this might be the slotkin break breaking points moment
that Medan is a legitimate concern. She's going to ask about
that legitimate >> Why does it need to be explained that
this is a problem that this is an issue? I don't think it needs
to be explained. It's obvious, but like
>> the main first sign in the back really screams no fascism.
What are we What are we doing here? The main fur side in the
back really screams no fascism. Uh-huh. >> Maybe it's like
a frog in a boiling water situation. You know, sometimes I feel
like I'm being gas lit. You know, sometimes I feel like I'm being
gas lit a bit. Like if we found out that a Republican nominee
for Senate had a Nazi tattoo and then they only got it covered
up like 3 days before a news story broke about it, we would all
be saying the same thing, which is like, "Oh my god, >> I
think he got it covered up after the news story." No, >> this
is crazy. I couldn't get access to the article cuz it was paywalled,
but I got a summary from Clotty Boy here. So, he's never going
to discover the actual discrepancy. He's never going to actually
see what happened here that makes the story suspicious. He'll
never see it. Fantastic
guys. I just listen. I couldn't get access to the article cuz
that's really hard. But I got Claude to summarize it for me.
According to the October 2024,
sorry, [clears throat] according to the October 24 2025 Kile
story by Andrew Kazinski, the specific claim is narrow but pointed.
The acquaintance who had known Platner more than a decade ago
recalled that Platner himself referred to the tattoo as quote
my toteen comp.
using the actual German SS terminology and did so in a joking
way. A few additional details that flush out the claim. The acquaintance
was originally a source for insider. Okay, that's where he got
that. Um but but Kay File did their own reporting here. Um which
broke that piece of the story.
Kayfile then independently interviewed the same acquaintance
who reiterated the recollection to CNN. Though this isn't one
outlet relying on another's reporting, both spoke to the source
directly. A second person told CNN they had learned of the tattoo
years ago from that acquaintance and that the acquaintance said
Platner had described it as a Nazi style design. That secondhand
corroboration that's a secondhand corroboration of the firsthand
claim.
So that is wild. It's Hold on.
Does Hutchnot realize that it is like years later? I feel like
he's still not noticed the time discrepancy that it wasn't contemporaneous
that it happened after after Platner was starting his campaign
after he was deciding to enter
Do we not get that? That's important.
That is wild. That corroboration is very
>> Very damning cuz it utterly annihilates.
>> I also would want to know like there are some questions
I would have here. Okay.
So reviewed. Oh, no, no, no, no. This one. We also reviewed a
text chain between the acquaintance and another person discussing
Platner's Nazi like tattoo several months ago before the story
became public. Platner's campaign declined a comment for this
story. Platner said in an interview this week, he got the skull
and crossbones tattoo. They denied comment. I mean, Platner's
commenting on it now. He says it's based on a time he didn't
even work at that bar.
And so I would want to know who it was who knew him. How well
did they know him, right? Like how well did they even know him?
And what was said in this text chain discussing plat and how
did was it organic how it came up? Like how much of this text
chain did you review cuz I could report that this happened and
this could be totally truthful
and it could be totally disconnected from whether or not you
knew him before and whether or not he did any of these things
that you're saying,
right? Like Kile is not saying we actually confirmed that he
had gone to this bar and met Platiner in some way. They're essentially
saying that, well, this guy told us a story. We could we we heard
the story. It's the same as the insider story. They don't clear
up the timeline either, which is a little
And then they to they told us, you know, this guy and his acquaintance
said they talked about it a few months ago. We understand that
that is not that is not incontrovertible evidence. That's not
proof of anything. Now, again, I will say as somebody who has
common sense, I don't believe he didn't know about the tattoo.
That's not what I'm saying. I'm saying that the idea that he
said it was my toteen cough for something. This whole thing,
this planted, this is a totally fabricated story in my opinion.
I just doesn't hold water. No, they didn't even verify the day
exists because the insider thing says 2012 and Graham Platner
says he didn't work at the tunein in 2012.
And this would be something that like if he were to lie here
about not working at the bar at the bar in 2012,
like you'd be kind of there. No. Was this the story that got
Josiah to change his opinion?
I assume this is Josiah and a bunch of other people changed their
opinion because of this and I don't know I again I don't know
if Josiah read the whole thing or not but I'm sitting here and
I'm like dude it's uh it's a little concerning that we didn't
look into this a little more deeply. you have like a first an
also hang on. Uh,
Kay File also reviewed a text chain between the acquaintance
and a third person discussing Platiner's quote Nazi like tattoo
several months before the story became public, meaning the acquaintance
was characterizing the tattoo this way privately.
>> So, we need to we need to know now,
do you identify the difference in timeline >> Well, before
there was any media incentive to do so. So, what is like the
most innocent explanation? Captain Flavor Town, if you believe
the anonymous sources. It's not just about believing anonymous
sources. How do you explain the texts? Captain Flavor Town, I've
asked you this three times now. How do you explain text messages
timestamped over a decade ago? Yeah, he didn't identify the time
discrepancy.
Un [sighs] lucky. Unlucky. Unlucky. Unlucky. Unlucky. Now, I
didn't get it from the video either, but once I went and read
the article, it became very clear, right? once you read literally
the the thing discussing the tattoo several months ago. Now maybe
there's maybe this is really bad English and they mean Tann also
reviewed a text chain between the acquaintances
the acquaintance sorry and another person discussing Platner's
Nazi like tattoo and we reviewed them several months ago before
the story became public but I don't think that's what it is.
It's like they discussed it several months ago before the story
became >> How do you explain that?
>> Is anybody gonna put platner? That's not my question.
How do you explain them? Disgruntled staffer. What would they
possibly get?
Do you understand what you're saying? But like a disgruntled
staffer, I don't First of all, I don't even know what that means.
Who's who's a disgrunt disgruntled staffer here?
But what would be the incentive to privately discussing
the tattoo with another
as soon as you find out about it? Like as in if this was going
through political influencer circles somehow or political not
influencer circles, political influence circles as in behind
the scenes with like people who do consulting and stuff that
this became like a story or something people found out about.
Why would you then have a private conversation about this thing
in order to essentially bootstrap a validation for the story
coming out that he knew for sure?
I don't know. Um money, power, influence, all of these things.
basically just all of the standard influences for why you would
politically rap somebody.
>> Like what would be the incentive for that? The existing
source from insider. None of you guys are grappling with the
text message. Like how the do you explain the text messages?
>> This is this is the Oh, this is the thing that got me
with Destiny
Do not be transparently ignorant and stupid and illiterate. Don't
be all of the worst things and arrogant at the same time. Holy
[__] When you're wrong and talking down to people,
you are making such an ass of yourself. Holy moly. Holy moly.
It's difficult to deal with. I don't want to listen to it, man.
I don't want to listen to you be arrogant and dumb at the same
time.
That chatter was right. Wait, what did the chatter say? >> Tattoo
with another person.
Like, what would be the incentive for that? the existing source
from insider. None of you guys are grappling with the text message.
Like how the do you explain the text messages? What is going
on? What is
>> they have text messages from 10 years ago? 10 years
ago. >> Oh, hold on. >> Happening.
Why am I being gas right now? Gaslighting me right now.
>> What the is happening? >> Are you really angry?
You really that concerned about a tattoo from 10 years >> Oh,
they have text message exchanges. private text message exchanges
between two people discussing his tattoo and like [laughter]
like how do you explain that? Oh, disgruntled staffer. What?
Like what would what would be the so so so this was an elaborate
plot? So this Okay. Yes. Yeah. You know what's
only defense is the time now. And it's so funny watching him
continually fall back to the time. And I'm just hoping we get
on stream the moment when he realizes that time discrepancy doesn't
exist and he melts. I I Come on. Come on, man. Please, let there
be a god. Let there be a god who could see me praying right now.
Whatever entity is listening, if you could hear me, please let
Hutch discover that that time discrepancy is fake. He made it
up in his own brain. Please, please, please. And then he's going
to melt. He has no other defense except he has no other defense
except for Well, it was 10 years ago, so they couldn't have made
it up. >> You've convinced me. This makes sense. So over
10 years ago, uh, someone who worked with Platner at like a bar
or something like that, they had the foresight to know that Grant
Platner was probably one day going to run for US Senate seat.
And so they did this text message exchange, it was a lie, so
they could have it there, and then wait for like 15 years later
for this guy to run for Senate. And it's like all that was like
they were playing the long game on that one. >> Come on.
Come on. They kept the text for 10 years. Weird. Nope. Nope.
It's you're >> It's all making sense now. It's all making
sense. Further proof hate keeps breaking everyone's brains. Oh,
look how look how arrogant they're getting. Oh, it's only anti-semitism
that's doing this, guys. If you didn't hate, you would just believe
this. You would just believe this that this all happened 10 years
ago. Nobody could have faked it at all, guys. If you if you just
would believe if you just weren't anti-semitic,
everything would be fine.
>> Speak like a normal person. But that comes with its
own challenges in the political world, which is you've used the
word, which I saw you apologize for this week. Uh, you've made
comments about women.
Um, Hutch does not think he's a cryptoni, apparently, but Hutch's
chat absolutely believes he's a cryptonazi. Also, there are some
people who are in his chat arguing against this idea, right?
So, there's there's some lefties in his chat, too, who are arguing
with him as well.
And Mills and Susan Collins have attacked you for uh there's
the tattoo.
>> He used the the the rler like 10 days ago, you know,
like >> Uh-huh. And I totally believe you care about that,
Hutch. I totally believe you care about that very deeply. Very
honestly, very deeply. It's like so important to you.
>> Yep. For sure. >> Whatever online discourse, I'm
not going to police people's
language. I gave up on trying to do that a long time ago. I have
my words that I say and don't say.
>> I'm just going to say something that I don't really
believe in. I'm just going to say something for no reason that
I don't really believe in cuz I just want to right now. I'm not
saying it's that bad, but actually he said like months ago. And
guys, doesn't that mean something? Doesn't that mean something,
So insanely disingenuous, man. Okay, I think that might be the
end of where I'm watching Hutch for for this stuff specifically.
Hutch, as of today, has blacklisted me. Am I hearing this correct,
guys? That Hutch has gone so far. He's fallen so far that he's
officially blacklisted me from this >> Ogre this I think
he starts talking about Ogre Boy. I think Ogre Boy is waiting
to talk to him about something and Hutch didn't want to talk
to Ogre >> Ladies and gentlemen, hang on. I did say I was
doing a blanket ban on Ogre Boy. It's tempting, but I have to
follow through on things. >> We did. We have a new blanket
policy.
>> Him. And who's the other one? >> Uh who's the
one that we just ri Riyle Kittenhouse? Who's uh Jtock?
>> I can't keep I can't V the dem. I can't keep feeding
these people.
>> I mean, I So, he never fed me once. He literally only
responded one time or two times. By the way, as soon as I tried
to respond in good faith, he opted out, right? The only thing
Hutch responds to, Hutch is like a um he's like somebody who's
like a glutton for punishment. He's like a he's like a masochist.
Okay. Every time I I was kind to Hutch for months and months
months and months, I was super charitable to him. I was overly
kind to him. Anytime he's brought up on stream, I'd take the
I would be charitable to him. Okay.
He blocked me over nothing. Somebody just said, "You should block
this guy." And he blocked me. He wouldn't talk to me. I want
to have legitimate discussions with him about politics. Since
then, I've realized that he is not really equipped for this sphere.
He's not very good at this, okay,
at all? And realistically, since he blocked me, I've never had
a chance to talk to him ever. He's never presented me with any
chance to talk to him. I gave up on talking to him a long time
ago. You are feeding me by being an overt and obvious [__]
on your stream every day. You can't stop doing it. Okay? That's
how I get these timestamps. That's how I get to go cover you
is because you put your foot in your mouth constantly. Just like
you did with Platiner and that whole story from Kfile, right?
Misunderstanding that openly on stream in a way that I could
benefit from massively. Thank you so much for that.
>> You're going to keep doing it and I'll get to keep I'll
get to keep feasting, man. I'll always get to feast.
>> Like, what does he think he's doing by saying he's going
to blacklist me? Do you think responding to me helped me? It
didn't. It It didn't do anything.
I don't need you to respond. What I would want you to do, cuz
your responses are totally bad faith. You don't actually listen
to any of the arguments. You didn't even attempt to. Why do I
I don't care to have a conversation with you. I'll just keep
pointing out that you're a [__] over and over and
over again. That's all I want to do. LIKE I I DON'T WANT TO TALK
TO YOU. I WANTED TO TALK TO YOU BEFORE.
Then you did some responses and you spent more time looking at
Destiny's wiki page and getting like stories from DJGers that
you spent actually analyzing what I was saying on the stream.
That told me everything I needed to know about you.
Why the would I want to talk to you? You should talk to Ogre
Boy, though. Ogre Boy doesn't really Ogre Boy just loves having
political arguments.
Ogre Boy isn't even mean. At least I'm mean. Well, I'm not really
mean. I could be mean. I'm not mean.
>> One last time. Stop trying to get Hutch back on cigarettes.
Well, cigarettes are pretty disgusting.
No, I'm not doing it, Ogre boy. No, no, no. I did a ban policy.
We're not doing this. By the way, I was super kind of Hutch constantly.
And it wasn't even that he stopped that he blocked me on everything.
I was still charitable to him after that. It was after he had
like repeatedly been bad faith with multiple people. After I
watched that debate he had with Pisco where he totally tried
to undercut his undercut Pisco with his expressions and get his
audience to like turn against him. I watched that happened and
I'm like, "Oh, this is a total piece of I see who this guy is
now. I see you."
That's when I started like or I I guess I stopped feeling any
charity towards Hutch. It wasn't even when he blocked me for
no reason based on the word of somebody who I don't even know
I don't even know who it was. I don't know if it was Destiny.
I think it could have been Desty, could have been Natsuerite.
Not totally sure.
It wasn't even then.